hello friends and welcome to another
episode of Danny opens boxes with video
games inside of them you may remember we
had over watch couple weeks back it's
time for doom this is a hundred and
twenty dollars available now although if
you're an Amazon Prime member you got a
cool three cents off so pop on knock
deal immediately at the original version
of the game is sixty bucks so you're
talking twice the asking price and for
that it apparently has a revenant statue
and a steelbook and that's it
so this statue better be the most
charming statue they've ever put in the
collector's edition if it's gonna be
worth the asking price so let's find out
batteries included apparently good sign
you don't to spend a hundred twenty
bucks then have to go buy a pack of
triple A's oh and here we have a
steelbook case which is rather fancy
nice cover I think I prefer this cover
actually inside of this there is a disc
for the game you're still gonna have to
download it via Steam anyway but it
probably has a couple of the files on
there and also included is not the
season pass per day ad for the season
bus but you do get the demon multiplayer
pack or if you're in French the pack
mulch is your demo neke maybe invite a
friend over to help with this part okay
so much like doom guy at the start of
the game it comes in a tomb which can be
opened this way the revenant not
Leonardo DiCaprio fighting off a bear
but instead a disgusting hell based
cyberdemon with rockets on his shoulders
nice detail it's got an ax he's on a
nice cool little platform as well that
looks pretty good apparently to some
sort of motion with this so let's stick
in the batteries and see what it does
alright that's it that's it there you go
it's all little I mean we should
probably cut the lights to see what it
looks like properly but that's it that's
that's what happens you put the
batteries in
I don't think the revenant himself
lights up at all I think he's just
hanging out being a real demon sob but
yeah this this little fan thing is
turning rather so at the bottom that's a
let's that's cut the lights and see how
its
does it all right that's that's it
that's him let up it in in the darkness
just hanging out
that's the statue it's $120 you just
just I mean yeah if you're a big fan of
the revenant the the character in Dhoom
not the movie this this might be worth
picking up was I mean it's not exactly a
big showpiece
to be completely honest but there you go
that's the 120 dollar collector's
edition of doom
available now on Xbox one Playstation 4
and PC or you can just pick up the
regular edition for 60 bucks the choice
is yours
you